nein nein genommen hat gelogen und
herzlich willkommen
zu dieser special folge müssen wir zu
schwach und auch ein intro hasst mich in
diesen hallo nachbarn in diesem haus
wohnt auch nur kinder kümmert die fan
von eine tolle reise bist jemand die
leute mussten gehen andere sind neu
dazugekommen
[Gelächter]
und zu dieser ganz speziellen
szenenfolge unternehmer heute das thema
ist heute und für diese ganz tolle folge
was nicht nur bis zur kaputten dein
konfrontation persönlichkeit entsprechen
nach 25 jahren immer noch nicht gefunden
hat
ich bin dieser sei sehr schwer gefallen
da muss ich mich auch direkt am anfang
mal verteidigen denn ich stecke in jedem
fall den wir hier machen etwas
persönlichkeit münchen schnaps trinken
sie in folge 3 kommt jetzt die bahn
weiter durch die immer kräftig und auf
dem i was endlich vorbei
zusammen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nicht
zufrieden mit hatte heute eine
honigmelone mitgebracht weil das habe
ich dann nie gearbeitet aber es schmeckt
lecker haben minze
ich habe einmal so gehen dass wir das zu
gehen und dann würde ich meiner mama ist
das weil sehr fruchtig aber gleichzeitig
ist schon ein gemacht mischung in den
ferrari unter den cocktails um einfach
ein bisschen displayweek endlich ich bin
sehr maskuline mein krieg
dazu brauche ich dann noch ein paar
beauty flutdämme lernen mit hat nur zwei
das gibt viele arten von dax zum
beispiel die zigarette und halten es
viele heutige nummer drei und als top-
natürlich geht es jetzt nicht mache
darauf hin dass man nicht machen ein
bisschen und damit hat sich jetzt mit
frischen himbeeren elementen stunde
weltklassik am sonntag also der war mal
frisch und ich jetzt einfach so wasser
pflaumenschnaps auch genannt im fach
muslime würden wieder hoch und lustige
strohhalme lust ich habe schon so viele
zutaten hat noch das korn weizen wir
wären möglich wissen lassen
jugendliche verabreden
maßstab transporter den schnaps her ist
es sagt was willst du bist du kaputt in
dein cola und rum und noch ne
sprudelwasser von kelly ich weiß wo es
auch los geht möchte ich noch eine sache
im pitch nämlich auch schon der patch
kaufmann buch funk wenn jetzt irgendwann
funk zuschaut oder ihre kontakte von
kraft oder wisst wo jemand vom punkt
holt dann sagt den leuten dann bräuchten
hinterlassen zeit mit der netten
botschaft wir brauchen eine serie und in
dieser serie geht es um drei erfolglose
influenza die eine war auf machen wollen
weil wir halt ein zweites standbein
brauchen bei die kooperation mit auf den
beiden ebenen scheiße ist schreibt das
jetzt bitte haben sie das video nicht
schaue ich mir die seite ist für die
zeit danach und 321 licht
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung wie man eine
honigmelone schnallen mittelblocker
bleibt oder gerade oder im blog law blog
weil okay ich mache einfach es ist ein
scheiß mit licht erscheint diese
explodiert
deine wohnungen egal sorry du möchtest
du musst mal mitmachen wer würde ich
gerne wieder dabei haben wir sind alle
fünf jura
[Musik]
ich wollte mit ihm will
nennen wir drei führend hinwil cocktail
company 3
keine gute idee
keine gute idee freunde keine gute idee
wie schiesse das ins auge
ich kann es nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
oh gott
[Musik]
erinnert mich an spannte warnte leute
schreibt in die kommentare instrumente
kenntnis der motivation skript wenn ich
nämlich das intro brauchten am meisten
teams und wenn wir dann anfang zu machen
dann weiß ich hab da ist immer schon so
cool beim schnitt aber das intro da sind
sich wirklich immer 8
viele menschen haben sich heute um sie
mir in den augen auszudrücken da
wirklich endlich wieder gefühle sind
doch mal war mein heimliches leben beim
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
honigmelonen geistert auch
[Musik]
ich muss mich mal ein zwei drei den er
haben schon weggeschnitten kann die
antwort nur
[Musik]
warum die jetzt verschiedene cocktails
und alarm wenn wir doch der eindruck
machen 90 zahlen im auge
[Musik]
an seiner waffe schmecken ich bin auf
diät
ich bin auf diät
ach komm ich machen
[Musik]
wir sind fertig und wer möchte einfach
komme ich vermag ich habe irgendwann
angefangen in der gemeinschaft und für
mich mal zuletzt habe ich schon einmal
nämlich mal als großer höhepunkt muss
ich das jetzt erklärt ja ok großer teil
meiner persönlichkeit die tschechische
kultur des flamen schnaps ist schnaps
ich habe daran gerochen ist ein
amtlicher in die kindheit ich jetzt so
ein bisschen angst so matthies buch von
denen das ganze getreten und abwischen
deswegen wollte ich den auch nicht einen
mixen dann drückt man traditionell immer
als chance
aber weil es sehr hart für euch werden
wird das kann ich jetzt schon sagen da
müsst ihr euch auch darauf warten
normalerweise kommt man mit bier nach
quellen hat mich immer an meine zeit in
berg es ist wirklich so ich an meinen ja
in berlin am hermannplatz gemacht aber
das war noch ein teil meines lebens 2 1
gewann kommt gesamtkonstrukt meiner
persönlichkeit zeitspanne hat meine
persönlichkeit sehr geprägt und sie
kommen doch irgendwann wieder zurück was
probiert als erstes jahr
fast den ganzen ja wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
was sie jetzt noch nicht keine gefühle
habe alles auf die tür zu weisen
dann ist vielleicht sehen wir
angeschoben
ich bin gekommen ja soll ich weiteren
gespendet okay wir haben hier drei tage
lässt das tablett zeigt meinen lebensweg
mit alkohol dass sie so fucking traurig
abflügen
also ich hab gedacht okay was beschreibt
mich am besten und es ist ein großformat
da habe ich gedacht ihnen erzähle euch
meine persönlichkeit und mein lebensweg
alkohol also in kurze geschichte bis 16
jahre alt auf schützenfesten unterwegs
im land ja was gerber weste und das
jetzt ausdrücken kartoffel gepflückt ich
hab das ohne witz seit zehn jahren
glaube ich nicht mehr nicht aus hass ist
wir haben erst recht nicht lecker dass
coca cola korn
vanessa 18 in der musik lagen in
heinbockel da gab es immer diese
tabletten cola korn für 10 euro ein aber
waren ebenso ein kleinlaster war richtig
groß
gestern 19 macht die fsj und entdeckt
auf wangerooge bananenbier und ihr
lieblings beträgt zwei jahre brauche
einfach das hintereinander für mich ganz
ausschließen würden vanessa 20 zieht
nach berlin und entdeckt gin tonic das
gitter getrennt haben wir uns
kennengelernt
wenn es hat 23
roger hat helicobacter und verträgt
absolut nichts mit und trinkt auf partys
nur noch da weil er nichts ist aus einer
wodka und wasser
vanessa 25 hat zwei antibiotika kuren
gegen den helicobacter gemacht und trägt
jetzt wieder champagner 2 und ehrlich
zehn folgen kopfball an das ist auch zum
feiern wie angewidert ja es ist einfach
dieser mixed es schon ich finde das sehr
hart
ich möchte da wirklich an dieser stelle
nochmal sagen es ist nicht
empfehlenswert ja bitte
[Musik]
also ich glaube ich habe ich erlebt was
tolles gemacht alter ich bin halt ich
bin ein typ ist richtig der dpa
die durch schwiegermütter nämlich auf
dem priwall schwiegersohn gesagt ich
hab' ich habe deswegen die perfekte mix
tour genommen von dem was mich ausmacht
auch der basis von dem was ich jetzt
momentan bin das ist mein ausgangspunkt
ist einfach die waffe von sturm waffe
bei dir das ganze waffe denn hat mich
schon in den letzten fünf sechs jahren
deutlich menschlich in richtung
gefördert dich sehr angenehm für ihn ist
meine basis und die habe ich extra noch
in plastik verpackt gelassen zieht
untersetzer den nur dann aber einfach
mal wenn du mittendrin kleines mädchen
hast kannst du dein untersätze einfach
anfangen zu essen aber das auch noch auf
plastik abstellen und es bleibt gekühlt
das heißt die ware schmilzt nicht ist
nämlich so eine halbe flasche schnaps
übrigens und dementsprechend ist einfach
ein ganz cooles effekt bei alltägliche
sachen mit was neuem cool der
selbstgemachten coolen cocktails für
mich aus es war ein ding in unserer
firma eine waffel unter dem getränk dazu
wie gesagt nicht rekurrieren ich habe
probiert ein bisschen zu arbeiten mit
frischen sachen also zum einen habe ich
zitrone kraft wird rein gemacht und die
zitronen haut für ein bisschen mehr drin
war und zum anderen werden habt doch den
rat gesucht und zu mal habe ich ein
bisschen minze klein gemacht dass alles
so ein bisschen ein zu machen
tatsächlich habe ich auch gelernt jetzt
mal ich habe alles gemacht
das habe ich dann gemacht und ab das
ganze auf getoppt mit ein bisschen chefs
auch mit dem gleichen geschmack das
heißt dass sich widerspiegelt klarer
schuss hier von pfirsich maracuja noch
mit rein von dem cocktail einfach nur
wegen dieser krassen farbe dass es in
tans geld leihen weil dieses gelbliche
freundlich ist und meine waffe ging
deswegen ist meine lieblingsfarbe
natürlich auch gelb und ist dann ist ja
mein lieblingsland das geld seit ich
drei jahre alt
[Musik]
ich mag mir diese für diese körper
verteilung von umarmen knutschen sowie
all of you und das ganze team sagte wir
sind mit den zielen lassen auch gut so
schmeckst du ein
komm auf 3 wer hat gewonnen ein 2 3-fach
sind könnten wir denn nur so geil weil
wir auf dem weg so besoffen geworden
sind nein wir schauen jetzt wirklich
also
immer wenn ich in ein videosystem so
lumma
[Musik]
akustisch juden video mediobanca
der vermieter will tut
[Musik]
angeschoben
es kam er wieder frei
die aktien geben
5 prozent
der frieden
nein
sinfonie und sie
[Applaus]
denn ein
sie sind
v
nein
warum sehen vom
und sie
chs la
die 7
mit judith von der auch ein dankeschön
an alle die zukunft seien die pro ist
momentan trafen die weihnachtslieder
funktionen die suppe kommentare
hinterlassen hat sich zwischen uns
entwickelt hat charisma das zeichnen
jetzt von dem könnte man natürlich
erstmal meine mama und ich noch richtig
viel gekocht und gemalt als das wort von
dirk an der zuschauer ist wichtig nach
alkohol